what do you wish theoretically inclined
students they knew about experiment what
should they know about experimental
physics I think most people don't
realize how much patience and
experimentalist needs and the fact that
the theorist gets to always think about
their Theory at the end of the day it
doesn't stop they pick it up exactly
where they left it the next day whereas
we turn our lasers off we spend the
majority of the time just getting the
laser back to where it was the day
before before we can even start our
experiment and so there's a lot of that
frustration that goes on but also I
think that we actually get to see
physics happening in front of our eyes
to me that's the most exciting part of
it is that we just get to see things
happening